The second design alternative I'm going to talk about
mitigates exactly the problem that I had mentioned earlier.
And that is, you want parallelism for accessing the
database because, this is probably one of the slowest link
in the whole processing of request because pulling in
data from the database is going to take a lot
of time. Both in terms of I/O that has
to be done through discs as well as the network
communication to pull in the data into
the container where the processing needs to happen.
And for that purpose the structure that we
have here is to push the business logic
as part of this container in which the
servelet and the presentation logic was there we
add the business logic also and make it
a three tier software structure here. Servelet presentation
logic and business logic, and all of the data access is going to be done
through what are called entity beans. As I mentioned earlier, entity beans have
persistence characteristics, and in this particular example
i can think of the entity bean
as representing one row of the database.
So the data access object are implemented
using a whole bunch of entity beans and you
can decide as the designer whether an entity bean
is responsible for one row of the database or
maybe for a set of rows of the database.
But in any event what we've done is, we've
taken the parallelism that is available in terms of
data access to the database and encoded it through
the entity bean so that they can be parallel access
to the unit of granularity that we have
in terms data base access. So the EJB container
now contains these entity beans. So now if a
servelet that is serving a particular client needs to
access some portion of the database, it can
form more parallel requests to these entity beans, to
as many entity beans as it wants. And all
of those entity beans can work in parallel on
behalf of a single client. And pull in the data that is needed and serve it
up to the business logic so that the business logic can then do its thing. So we
are reducing the time for data access by
having this parallel structure and exploiting the available concurrency
that may be there in terms of I/O
performance, and also even if there are parallel requests,
those parallel requests may want access to the
same portion of the database. If you think
about the example I gave you of two
difference individuals wanting to make airline reservation for
exactly the same dates and the same set
of constraints. Then there may be an opportunity
for this entity bean to cluster the request
coming from several different end clients and amortize the
access to the database server. Across several
different clients that are temporally happening at
the same time. And i mentioned entity
beams usually are dealing with persistent state,
which means that the persistence has to be provided at some level to these
entity beans. So that persistence has to be provided to the data accessed object
at some level, which are using these entity
beans. It could be done at the level of
individual entity beans. Which is called the bean
managed persistence. If the bean is managing the persistence
needs of the data access object, then that
is called bean managed persistence. Or it could be
that the container is providing that facility, in
which case the persistence needs of the data access
object is provided by the container and,
and that is called container managed persistence. So
these are two different design choices we
can make in this structure. The structure is
the same for the design alternate of two. That is, we're using entity beings to
implement data access objects, and we're deciding the
granularity of the data access object, based on
the level of concurrency that you want
in constructing this application service. But within
that choice there are two possibilities again
in terms of how we provide persistence for
the data access object, either by providing
it in the entity bean itself, or using
the container service to provide that. So
this, once again, points to opportunities for reuse
of facilities that may be available. The
same container-managed persistence may be usable for
different types of applications. One application may
be an airline application, another application may
be a portal for hotel booking. All of those different applications may be able
to reuse container-managed persistence that's available in
the structure. So the pros of this
structure is first of all, the concurrency
that you can actually exploit concurrency for
data access for the same client in parallel or even across different clients by
amortizing the data access. That may be
needed concurrently for similar services that are
overlapping in terms of data usage. That's
the good news. There's one con to this
approach, and that is, because we moved
the business logic into the web container from
the EJB container, it exposes the business logic
to the outside network. We are not confined
to the corporate network but the business logic
is exposed outside the corporate network in this
design alternative. So, all the data access code
that you used to be in the session
beam in the previous structure that I talked about.
All the data access code is now moved into
this entity beam. That's how we get the parallelism
in the fact that there are multiple entity beams
that are carrying the same data access code and
they could be accessing different portions of the database
concurrently resulting in exploitation of parallelism and reusing the
latency for the business logic to get all the
data it needs from the data base in order to do its work.